Traduttore: Alberto Pagani
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
Buonasera
Io sono stato un AFS student,
era il 1981.
I miei figli mi chiedevano:
"ma avevate la televisione a colori?"
Perché è inconcepibile
che non ci fossero i videogame
ma neanche la televisione a colori.
Ed erano le stesse domande
che mi facevano
quando arrivai in America.
Le ragioni per cui sono qua sono tante,
sono più per un invito che ho accolto
con stupore...
c'è gente molto più qualificata
a parlare di AFS e intercultura.
Stasera abbiamo avuto dei viaggi:
un viaggio fotografico,
un viaggio all'interno
di una storia di un paese,
un viaggio all'interno delle persone,
e anch'io ho un piccolo viaggio.
Il mio viaggio è, a sedici anni, partire.
Per partire ci vuole coraggio e curiosità.
Credo siano due cose
che caratterizzano
l'esperienza interculturale.
O di qualunque scambio.
A sedici anni avevo un'idea dell'America.
Hollywood,
Dallas, voi non sapete cosa sia,
Dynasty, le faide,
per me New York, la quinta strada,
erano tutta l'America,
andavi in giro per una città
ed era la quinta strada.
Fifth Avenue. No?
Questo era il mio modo di immaginarla.
Gli amici a scuola erano
quelli di Happy Days, The Fonz.
Questo era un drive in, American Graffiti,
chi non ha visto quelle macchine,
e questa era l'idea di cosa
si facesse di pomeriggio.
E sono arrivato con un impatto diverso.
Arrivo prima in una città,
poi mi sposto in un'altra,
questa fisicamente è la mia casa,
questa è la mia Dallas.
Questo è il mio American Graffiti.
Questa è la mia 5th Avenue.
Perché dov'ero io c'erano laghi,
io ero in New Jersey
a solo 30 minuti dalla NJ Turnpike,
più all'interno dove c'è un lago
che fa da riserva d'acqua di New York,
ma nella parte interna dove c'è
un lago più piccolo
che si chiama Wanaque...
e qua avviene tutto.
E questa è la mia scuola,
questo è l'impatto perché questo
è stato il mio anno.
Ed è un anno in cui io ho vissuto,
ho cambiato amici,
ho cambiato tante cose,
ma fondamentalmente ho scoperto
due cose importanti.
La prima è "chi sei".
E tu sei chi sei ovunque tu sia,
puoi cambiare il tuo atteggiamento.
La seconda è che la gente
si aspetta da te delle cose.
Indipendentemente
dalle cose come sono in realtà
si aspetta da te quelle cose.
Arrivo il primo giorno,
mi portano in macchina a scuola,
entro, c'è la coda, apro la porta, esco,
quando usciamo mi devo far trovare
nel parcheggio
perché mi vengono a prendere
e c'è una ragazza che arriva con tre libri,
trenta fogli, quella classica scena,
e lei cerca di aprire la macchina.
Appoggia un libro sulla macchina,
le cade un foglio,
io mi avvicino e le apro la portiera.
Lei mi guarda, sorride.
Ma non è il sorriso
di una che ti sorride per gentilezza,
sorride di stupore.
Chiariamoci, aprire le porte per me
a sedici anni era una cosa che si faceva
per le ragazze al cinema,
in America a sedici anni si guida
e quindi tu puoi aprire
la portiera a una ragazza.
A Milano in bicicletta o in motorino
non si aprono porte,
aprire la porta a un autobus
è impossibile.
Aprii la porta della scuola
per far passare due ragazze
che mi guardano e sorridono.
E io sono diventato il cascamorto.
"Oh! The love-smitten. Oh!"
E ho scoperto che le ragazze
si attardavano
quando arrivavo, per farsi aprire la porta.
Sembra una battuta
ma non avete idea di cosa
ha causato a Ringwood... la guerra.
Perché ogni singolo fidanzato, amante,
candidato, a questo punto
aveva un problema:
"Oh, Paolo is so cute!"
(Paolo è così carino!)
E correvano ad aprire le porte.
La cultura si basa sul fatto di avere
dei comportamenti condivisi
che aiutano i componenti ad avere
atteggiamenti accettabili o familiari.
Io ero in una nuova cultura,
conoscevo gente nuova,
vedevo cose nuove.
È qua che ci voleva il coraggio.
Questo è quello che AFS
mi ha permesso di fare
in maniera semplice.
Ma c'è un percorso più importante:
il percorso è quello che mi ha permesso
di fare delle cose che altrimenti
io non avrei mai fatto.
Grazie a questa esperienza
ho imparato delle piccole lezioni
tra cui la numero uno:
mai, mai, mai, mai, mai arrendersi.
Mai, mai, mai darsi per vinto.
E mai, mai, mai
prendere in giro l'underdog.
L'underdog è colui che parte
svantaggiato
ma alla fine vince.
Questo è l'underdog, quello che ce la fa.
Come Roberta Vinci
che batte Serena Williams
e che dice "I'm sorry" (Mi dispiace)
Come? "Today is my day, I'm sorry"
(Oggi è il mio giorno, mi dispiace)
Io sono stato l'underdog,
mi hanno messo
nella squadra di football
solo perché ero veloce, non pensate,
non ho fatto nulla di eclatante
ma ero molto veloce.
Mi allenavo con gli altri,
ero parte della squadra
ma facevo lo scaldapanchine.
Ho passato i primi due mesi
a scaldare panchine,
ma ho capito che far parte della squadra
voleva dire partecipare alla squadra
anche dalla panchina.
Io sono bravo a leggere i giochi,
sono sempre stato bravo
a capire come si muovevano le cose.
Così ho detto al mio coach,
in una partita in cui perdevamo brutalmente
e io ero intonso, bianco, bellissimo
mentre tutti erano sporchi di fango,
"sulla destra il cornerback non ce la fa"
è sguarnito,
pensando che facesse giocare gli altri.
Lui dice ok e si guarda in giro:
il porta acqua era stanco anche lui,
la mascotte era a pezzi, c'ero io.
E mi manda in campo.
Prima azione, vengo messo a terra,
mi saltano addosso sulla testa
e bevo l'acqua della pozzanghera.
La seconda azione me la ricordo ancora,
il quarterback mi dice:
"Paolo, 10 e dentro"
Io, allo snap, 10 yard e dentro.
Tanto vedo che lui mi volta le spalle
e sta guardando Kevin
il numero 88, io ero il numero 16.
Nessuno vuole il 16 a football.
Il numero 88 è il ricevitore.
E tira quello che viene chiamato
un ground-to-ground missile.
È una bordata, dritta,
solo che piove, a dirotto
e Kevin prende la palla,
gli rimbalza in mezzo alle mani
la prende nel casco
e la palla carambola.
Palla libera, chi la piglia è sua
e io sto correndo.
A chi arriva la palla? Qua.
Io la prendo e lì la vocina:
corri corri corri corri corri corri corri.
E io corro, ma sono il tipico italiano,
alto un metro e novanta
ma tipico italiano,
con un ottimo accento italiano
ma sono alto e sono veloce.
E io corro.
Mi ferma il safety,
mi si butta in mezzo alle gambe,
io mi alzo, salto e dico "T'ho fregato"
e in quel momento mi arriva
lo strong safety.
E io faccio quello che in gergo si chiama
flying UFO, faccio due giri su me stesso
e atterro. Sono a pezzi.
Sono in una pozzanghera.
Esco fuori e sono bagnato,
ho sabbia, terra qua,
mi fanno male le mani
e mi dico che il coach come sempre
mi chiamerà fuori.
Rimango in campo.
Esco dal mio game quando è il momento
e sono Hoagie, the Italian missile.
Hoagie è un panino.
E da quel giorno io sono Hoagie.
Sono l'underdog e sono stato accettato.
Ed è lì che inizia la mia avventura
perché è lì che mi faccio gli amici.
Quando la mia avventura finisce
in un bus stop il 12 giugno
dove ci sono ragazze
che si abbracciano,
c'è la tua fidanzata, c'è tutto,
lì è il momento del sunto.
Perché tu sei vuoto, triste
perché stai partendo
per un nuovo viaggio,
stai tornando a casa,
ma ti porti dietro un nuovo bagaglio.
Questo è il bagaglio che mi ha permesso
di andare avanti e di fare altre cose.
Poi sono tornato in America per studiare,
ho fatto un Master,
ho lavorato solo
per società anglosassoni,
ho lavorato credo in tre continenti
e ho avuto la fortuna di lavorare
in società che mi hanno permesso
di accedere a gente straordinaria.
Ho imparato quattro piccole regole,
la prima regola è teamwork,
lavoro di squadra.
Non il lavoro di squadra all'italiana
non mi fraintendete,
non c'entra nulla il teamwork
come ve l'hanno insegnato.
La società americana funziona
in modo che la famiglia, il quartiere,
la tua municipality, il tuo sindaco...
se tu sei in grado
di contribuire fattualmente
trovi spazio,
ed è questo il teamwork.
Vince Lombardi è uno
dei più grandi allenatori
di football americano
e insegna il gioco di squadra
inteso come elemento differenziante
di una società
perché funziona così
anche il governo degli Stati Uniti
con tutte le pecche che ha.
Il secondo punto importante
che ho imparato sul campo da football
grazie ad AFS ma poi lavorando
per investment bank
e fondi di private equity
è che soltanto chi sa obbedire
e capisce cosa deve fare
può permettersi di comandare.
Perché comandare non è uno
che vi dice cosa fare,
quello non è comandare,
quello è imperare.
Un leader vi spiega la missione,
dove vogliamo andare,
ma lo fa perché anche lui
ha capito come farlo
e c'è una delegazione di potere.
Quando parlate
con un responsabile americano,
anche fosse l'ultimo della catena,
in quel momento voi parlate
col più alto in grado.
A lui viene demandato il potere
e non se ne approfitta perché tanto,
se fa male il suo lavoro,
verrà punito, non sarà più lì,
non potrà andare avanti
nella sua carriera.
Questo è stato importante perché
in consulenza io non dovevo
dare gli ordini ai miei clienti,
io dovevo essere bravo
a fare quel lavoro.
Bravo ad aiutarlo
a raggiungere l'obiettivo.
La cosa più importante
da italiano che ho imparato
alla high school
è seguire le regole, compilare i moduli.
Compilare bene i moduli
mi ha permesso di andare
a fare application
in suole a cui sinceramente
io a 16 anni non pensavo.
Ho avuto l'opportunità
di andare a studiare
in tre grandi scuole
e ho scelto Wharton,
la più elitaria scuola di business
al mondo, credo.
Lì ho trovato gente
per cui ero di nuovo l'underdog.
Ma è fare bene i moduli,
non prendere scorciatoie è importante:
in America c'è il concetto che
Cheating is bad
(imbrogliare è sbagliato)
infatti ti permettono di portare
i libri agli esami.
Perché? Perché tanto puoi
copiare da un libro,
ma se non sai dove devi guardare
che copi a fare?
Quindi ti lascio il libro,
non devi imbrogliare in un altro senso,
non devi prendere scorciatoie.
Se devi fare una cosa falla, falla bene,
se non sei capace alza la mano,
teamwork.
Ma l'ultima cosa, la più bella
che ho imparato
è essere pragmatici.
E qui ho citato Bono,
erano gli anni 80 e ci voleva Bono.
Essere pragmatici vuol dire
rimboccarsi le maniche.
C'è un fil rouge in questo mio discorso,
ed è che credo che AFS,
col fatto di prendere ragazzi
in un'età acerba ma già avanti,
che gli permetta di andare
a cimentarsi in un nuovo ambito,
permetta di espandere la loro cultura,
il loro sistema di valori.
Io sono un mix di tre sistemi:
italiano dove sono nato,
americano dove ho vissuto e lavorato,
e anglosassone che è molto diverso.
Quello che cerco di trasmettere
ai miei figli
è una nuova cultura,
forse ancora più ampia
che prenda un po' del meglio degli altri
in modo tale che ogni volta
che uno dei ragazzi parte,
lo faccia con un bagaglio più ampio
e possa ampliarlo ancora.
E credo che ogni volta
che qualcuno parte
crea davvero un mondo migliore
dove ci si capisce un po' meglio.
Io mi occupo di turnaround,
questo è molto soft per me,
ma quando vado in un'azienda
non conosco,
sono di nuovo l'underdog
sono quello nuovo che arriva,
non ho la cultura,
ce l'hanno loro.
Io devo portare parte della mia cultura
in questa azienda e parte dei miei valori,
ma devo prendere anche dai loro valori
perché le aziende non si stravolgono.
E io sono molto grato a Intercultura
perché mi ha permesso
un viaggio che altrimenti
non avrei mai potuto fare,
ma è il mio viaggio
e io ringrazio tutti quanti voi
perché l'avete condiviso.
(Applausi)